so you mentioned earlier that something
happened during the filming that was on
you but you one of your actors thought
maybe it was their performance
how do you give constructive notes
what's the best way to do that with an
actor knowing that to that they're
fragile and aren't usually in front of
many people on set maybe not so much on
salon demons right androids I think it's
different with every director if there's
so many you know each director has their
own they set their own tone on the set
how they work you know I the extroverted
introvert or do they do they use their
ad to talk to people or do they do
themselves I mean I think it's so
different I don't think there's one
right way to do it the way I do it
though is I just try to be as genuine as
possible and I encourage them and as all
directors say just try to create the
comfortable environment where they don't
feel taking a risk is going to get
laughed at you know if there's something
that we want to try we want to try it
without being judged you know just kind
of creating that environment where
everyone is just kind of if it's it if
it doesn't turn out is what we thought
was going to be that's fine you know
we're going to try it a different way
and that's a try that's damaged or I try
to set up for them for the actors let's
put you in the actors shoes from let's
say you're on set and
have several takes whatever it is
whether it's a line that's misspoke or
something and how would you want to be
approached by someone what would be the
best way to kind of save face or to help
univ it's not saving facebook that's
funny because I did have a cameo if this
as you recall in sherman song and I the
joke about the set on that day is I I in
mid-sentence in mid line if I messed up
I would just cut myself and just walk
out of the room and come back in and
without saying cut so just admit you
know mid take I just feel like just
leave and then the crew just be busting
out laughing and stuff so I don't know
like I think um I just asked him to the
Kubrick museum the the exhibit and it
was amazing and there was a story that
Ryan O'Neal I think had where he said
there was a really really tough day
trying to get through a scene and when
he finally finally got through it the
breakthrough when Kubrick was walking to
talk to his crew he has walked by and
grabbed his hand and gave it a squeeze
and kept walking like that's all he did
he just give him a touch like
acknowledgement that he had done it
anybody want to walk to talk to his
cameraman or something else and I think
with me and my actors I have that that
bond were sometimes it is just that look
that does not right just it's sometimes
you don't have to say it sometimes I do
pull them aside privately to give them
some some pep top or feedback on
adjustments or other things to try
without other people knowing about it
again it's just it kind of depends even
with myself on the sets on who I'm
talking to each actor wants to be told
differently different things you know
they all don't have the same way to
respond to correcting
you